hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV I am at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and I'm
pleased to be joined by dr. Jeffrey
singer doctor for liberty as his email
goes I can personally attest dr. singer
thank you for joining us
Jeff singer wrote a great piece for
reason one of the most remarks upon
pieces that we've run this year about
doctors going Gault a process that's
been happening over the last 30 or so
years but has been goosed a bit more
with Obamacare tell us about this
concept what happened to doctors well
over the past 30 to 40 years government
involvement in medicine has resulted in
a progressive regimentation of medicine
and doctors are being forced to
basically adjust their practices to
comply with protocols and guidelines
that are drawn up by regulators in
Washington they're being forced to try
to describe what they do both in order
to get paid for what they do and in
order to in order to comply with
guidelines in in the form of very
complicated codes that have been again
devised essentially a lot of it actually
aided abetted by some of the
professional organizations like the
American Medical Association which has a
government-granted monopoly on on the
design of these codes and so that over
the past three or four years now doctors
have found that they're losing their
autonomy many of them vinay will afford
to stay in practice so they're selling
their practices and becoming employees
of hospitals or large corporate clinics
and they're being reduced to shift
working employees were compelled to
follow guidelines and protocols that
tell them how to practice and they spent
a great deal of the time entering data
into computers because they're also
forced to do everything electronically
again in compliance with templates
throwing up by the regulators now let's
say let's say I go to you your what kind
of surgeon or I'm a general surgeon
general surgeon so I go and you I my
gall bladders give me the Dickens at the
time and you're going to diagnose me and
hopefully
that damn thing out where does this come
in in the process how does this go into
your specific practice well my specific
practice I'd have to use preoperative
preparation orders and do preoperative
testing that complies with guidelines
and protocols that are join up for me
and while you're in the hospital what
happens if you don't do that well then
I'm I'm being I'm being monitored
constantly if I if I deviate from the
guidelines I have to document
electronically in the electronic record
my reason for deviating and there are
acceptable reasons and there are other
others that aren't acceptable after a
certain amount of deviations I I stand
out now hospitals are being told that if
they don't get 80 percent of compliance
with these protocols and guidelines from
their medical staff you're going to be
penalized by having to give back money
to Medicare that they've already been
paid for services that they've rendered
so the hospital's leaned on the doctors
to follow these guidelines of course as
more and more doctors or employees of
hospitals it's easier for them to lean
on them because they just ordered that
to follow the guidelines since they're
their employees if they're still those
those may be 30 to 40 percent of doctors
who are still independent private
practitioners they just get you know
they pleaded with by the hospitals to
follow the guidelines and you know most
of us we want to be team players so we
try when we can as long as we agree with
the guidelines we try to do our best
meanwhile this atmosphere has basically
destroyed the feeling of professionalism
and it's also created a lot of ethical
dilemmas for us physicians because for
example I take an oath to put the
interest of my patient
paramount ahead of everything else in
fact my patient's interest come ahead of
the interest of my patients significant
other or any or anything else that's my
obligation but if if I'm being compelled
to practice according to guidelines and
protocols which are drawn up by
ultimately the payer which is in in most
cases Medicare is the driver of this
thing so and the reason the payer is
drawing these up is because the payer is
convinced that this will lead
to a more cost-effective allocation of
that payers resources
well then ethically I'm in a dilemma
here because I'm being forced to
practice with the interest of the payer
coming ahead of the interests of my
patient in many cases sometimes it will
coincide but it doesn't necessarily have
to now that's a that's an ethical credo
more fitting to a veterinarian because
when you're a veterinarian of course a
person brings to you their let's say
their dog your primary obligation is to
the owner of the dog not to your patient
the dog so you'll tell the owner right
you know I could do this I could do that
which which course would you like me to
follow I could I could do something
palliative I could even do some
euthanasia you tell me because you're my
client you the owner
well but in in human medicine of course
there there's no conflict between the it
shouldn't be a conflict between the
interests of the payer and easiest of
the patient because I think an oath only
to be concerned about the interest of my
patient but if I'm being compelled to
practice according to the interests of
the payer I'm actually being put in an
ethical boxy and ethical bind here these
kind of issues are driving a lot of us
experienced doctors who were planning to
practice another ten to fifteen to
twenty years to say I didn't sign up for
this and we're looking for the exits and
you are actually looking for the exit
I'm looking for the exits I haven't
exited yet but I'm I have a plan at
least you're writing about it and loving
this the rest of us know and I've gotten
feedback from other doctors saying he
finally you know wrote about this thing
that we're all experienced so thank you
for that check out the article doctors
going Gault had a reason calm for reason
TV with Jeffrey singer I am Matt Welch
you